former Vice President Joe Biden and
senator Bernie Sanders are both in
Michigan today ahead of tomorrow's
Democratic presidential contest six
states will hold votes for 352 delegates
that includes Mississippi Missouri
Michigan Idaho North Dakota and
Washington of those Michigan is the big
prize that has the most delegates 125 of
them today Sanders added a roundtable
with public health experts to address
fears of the coronavirus and our Ed
O'Keefe reports from Grand Rapids
Michigan
neither Joe Biden nor Bernie Sanders
appear to be making significant changes
to their campaigns amid the spread of
coronavirus but the Sanders campaign did
set up these hand sanitizers at an event
at the University of Michigan and while
Biden used some before meal in
Mississippi the focus for both men is
the races on Tuesday Sanders has L half
a dozen events in Michigan since Friday
he's hoping this is where he can block
Biden's momentum we're taking on the
wall street executives who are helping
to fund his campaign and hoping to boost
his support among black voters who he
struggled to win over Sanders campaigned
on Sunday with civil rights leader
Reverend Jesse Jackson who endorsed the
senator I said would burn the sentence
today because you still with me so far
Biden has overwhelmingly won the support
of black voters from Virginia to the
Carolinas Biden raised 22 million
dollars last week and is now pumping at
least 12 million dollars of advertising
into some states voting this week and
next the goal is to amass a big enough
delegate lead that Sanders can't catch
him on Sunday by Tanner yet another
endorsement from a former opponent this
time senator Kamala Harris I believe in
job I really believe in him and I have
known him for a long time her
endorsement comes after a particularly
bitter exchange last summer when she
questioned his record on civil rights
you also worked with them to oppose
busing and you know there was a little
girl in California who was part of the
second class to integrate her public
schools
she was bused to school everyday and
that little girl was me here in Grand
Rapids bita makes an appearance at this
health center this morning and then
he'll be joined by yet another new
supporter New Jersey senator Cory Booker
just announced he's endorsing his former
rival they will campaign together later
in Flint and then that campaign rally
tonight in Detroit Michele and thank you
and I'm glad you mentioned that